this is Mark Billy Billingham he served
in the British SAS for over 17 years has
been responsible for planning and
executing strategic operations across
the world is a certified
counter-terrorism instructor has led
countless hostage rescues as well as
much more today he's joining us to break
down more of the iconic SAS missions
from across the Call of Duty franchise
but in that position where people have
been close and the village walks right
past us all over us he's free just like
they did there just watch it Go by let
it happen we've got a few more videos
with Mark planned taking him through
many more of the Call of Duty SAS
missions across the franchise so be sure
to subscribe for that and if you want to
see more of Billy Billingham you can
check out the links to all of his
socials as well as where to buy his new
books survive to fight in the
description below right over to Billy
it's the FNG sir
how easy on him sir it's his first day
on the regiment
so if it's your turn for the CQB test
everyone else head to Observation for
this test you'll have to run the cargo
ship Solo in less than 60 seconds okay
so basically it's just training scenario
it's a counter terrorist type training
scenario and for this they're using the
the stronghold being a bolt or a ship or
a you know a cruise or whatever it is it
doesn't matter so this is really you're
working on more of the speed than the
sort of uh the finer tactics at this
stage so that's pretty realistic in that
respect what you actually do and how you
do it is down to your training team what
the thing they wanted they want to type
knock on in this case it looks like you
want to be able to move quickly and
everything's going to be it's gone
aggressive let's just go for it it's not
a stealthy sort of test he's doing here
they're great mnemonic speed aggression
surprise SAS speed aggressive surprise
that's the speed and the aggressive side
of it being brought into it or is a
realistic part of the training you know
you've got to have the speed aggression
identify Target and taking the
initiative so that's what that's about
so to this point here okay this works
pretty good so
I've seen better
the man's smoking cigarettes
ain't gonna be out man
what's the gone as it is this is
probably one of the worst
scenarios we can find ourselves in in
reality for the regiment it's called
ships on the way it ships out in the
friggin ocean which the SBS would mean
they would take the lead on this it's
going to involve air acids and see above
the water possibly below the water
assets to to take this target down so
the SPs would probably lead on this most
likely with a joint planning team from
us of course
Channel
[Music]
three
secure hold your fire so the first roll
um entry onto the ship is very realistic
however what you will have is two or
three people on that road at the same
time that's so fast because you've got
it you know what happens to happen is
the helicopter comes over the ball you
gotta remember the helicopters moving
the boat's moving it's going up and down
it's doing all this it's really
dangerous as soon as that rub the first
guy's watching that Rob it's the deck
Eagles that's your cue that me behind
you to as soon as his head disappears
below my feet I'm on the road and the
next one on the next one because what
happens is if you go down and waiting
for a gap by the time you started going
the boat might have dropped down it's
now not on the ball it's over the side
and you're going into into the organ so
it's really fast sharp everybody down
the other point I'm just going to pick
up on that is we never use automatic
ever unless it's
conventional Warfare fighting against
trenches in the open battlefields no we
just don't use automatic because I don't
care how good you are I think you are
you cannot control it good enough for
what we do all our
shooting in this scenario type shoot is
instinctive and it's you know it's
accurate
100 actually it's always the best you'll
be doing is double Taps come on come on
not automatic about that
automatically fired again there wouldn't
be any automatic file like that the use
of the pistol across that distance
possibly or you're more likely sort out
your stoppage on your rifle because
you've got two or three teams there just
go to go down on one knee quickly sort
your stoppage out move with the team
again however if it's happening it's all
fast and possible but you may want to
pull your pistol back that sort of
distance it doesn't look far but you've
got to be especially five wheel
respirator move is difficult just very
minor things
[Music]
unrealistic there but there you go
yeah the pilots are good mate they ain't
that good if I'm honest
too much radiation
follow me and keep low scenario is great
really good
um this is a nitty little thing here
you've got captain and lieutenants never
in a million years no officers or
ruperts do that any of the real good
stuff let me tell you that it doesn't
happen that those sort of stuff is the
blogs Target approaching from the north
take him out quietly or just let him
pass just Tango down
equipment's good you know they're in
ghillie suits the the rifles are pretty
realistic nice slow methodical good
movement good we've got good cam on
the visuals are great
for realism
the visuals are good the visuals around
is really good you actually can feel it
you know you've been I've been in that
position where people are [ __ ] close
I say what do you do you just freeze
just like they did there just watch it
Go by let it happen you just you're just
in the hands of the Gods and all this
moments and that come across good it's
pretty nerve-wracking they do they come
right and close to you and then you know
you've gotta if if you do get pinged
then it's it's you compromise then then
all LL Breaks Loose you either shoot or
detain or do whatever you want to do but
yeah I've been in situations where that
on a number of situations where they are
not the principal that's not the main
part of the target let them go and
they've literally walks right past us
all over us where we're actually doing a
covert Mission and we hadn't got to the
point where we needed to be and we had
we had the enemy coming towards us it
just happened to turn up and it came
they looked like they'd seen us they
were coming right to us at the stock
that had 10 meters from us you could
hear them talking they hadn't seen as
they're just talking about what they
think that they might have seen or heard
looking Beyond this turned around and
walk back in the parts pounding for that
moment and so you can imagine that guy
they're lying in the grass and watch it
and especially once it's gone beyond you
because you're the last thing you can't
get up and look behind you that's
compromise you just got to accept I know
you haven't been seen you know but I've
been in that situation a couple of times
so you've captured that pretty well
that's good fire on the two by the Lorry
we'll have to take him out at the same
time I'm in position take the shot when
you're ready
good night when they took the
assimilated shot they've already just
says we're going to take those two out
together that would that's again put the
control on that okay you you're taking
left I'll tell you right confirmed got
it standby standby go so it would be
very controlled okay I've got left I'll
go you ready stand by go boom you know
I've been being a sniper as well
everybody identifies the target yeah
confirmed and you know the controllers
then can see every light on you know
I've got my target you've got your time
he's got his Target that's wait wait
wait he's got his Target got all then
one word command standby
standby gold and on that goal everywhere
and it's almost bang one shot that's why
you never or should it price the meeting
is underway enemy transport cited
entering the target area
it's good the way you're identifying the
issues of actually doing a long-range
shot to win
take the shot
gotta get down I think I saw his Adam
fly off I swear
the realism of it you know that
long-range shot you ain't probably ain't
gonna go for a head show you're going to
go for Mass chest area the wind the
elevation you get the um the the heat
rising you know you mentioned a number
of things there which people who've
never really done anything well that's
that's the realism that's good so the
realism in that is really good because
you've got the direction of travel with
a flag so you know which way to aim off
and the comms is good all the way
through talking through and then this
compromise compromises [ __ ] ratchet
let's go you just got to make the most
of it and yeah so that that's a great
great loss of oil it's a good that's a
real good one lighter
let's go
it's entertaining it's good it's
bullsey's gritty Mountain troop
um in the regiment as usual I was in
that's a scary type of stuff if you work
environments you're working in training
but again we're not stupid you know
you'd be robbed to be protection there's
all that stuff which takes you away from
the the Johnny Rambo gun Hall stuff but
reality that's what you would have
however it's good it's entertaining good
luck man I'll See You In The Far Side
you know that running late with the old
ice axes
yeah whatever whoever's gonna do that
I'd be like yeah you're on your [ __ ]
on me I ain't coming
and I was a manager of leader so
I mean basically what that radar would
be is a thermal imagery piece of Kit
one two three actually done okay so
we're keeping it covered
it's a stealth mission
go to plan B
yeah it's James one minute it's
entertaining
you know starting off as a stealth
mission
and then you end up taking out
enemy forces just with two of you so I
mean I can see sort of he took some of
the stuff of um like Pebble Island where
they would work at his small teams going
in taking out the with the aircraft on
the ground that sort of stuff
um so in terms of a scenario it's a good
little scenario but of course he's
turning to Johnny Rambo stroke James
Bond strong whatever you know but in
terms of entertainment that's what it is
it's entertainment it's not makes us
look good but we ain't that [ __ ] good
15 seconds out
boys we're on
nicely
who is our entry point
is that the dog just being shot all
right
good the movement's great the engagement
of targets and reaction of you know
somebody being hit is real
punch hunt
it's just as it is it's exactly like you
know the furniture Rider the equipment's
right the movement's right the
terminology the noises you're hearing
above outside the out you know the
helicopters and all that it's really
good
I'm getting into it's bringing it's
quite hairs on the back of my neck
on me
the picture there is he's you know he's
lifted his goggles up and he's talking
with the guy with the beard he saw us
I've pictured that a million times hey
Billy hey John Bob
and that would be the blogs you know
rank goes out of the window it's down to
that that's the only thing I'd pick up
on if there's anything you know part of
our ethos we're classless you know
there's no pizza yes sir ma'am there's
none of that we're all equal so as I was
a sole major the newest guy that come
into my team
you know he calls me Billy and I call
him John or Bob whatever his name is you
know we all know who's in the packet
orders on the bosses or something he's
leading the oh we all know that but I
mean that's very minor stuff but the
actual detail you know the things I said
equipment terminology movement tactics
to scenario calculate every bit of that
I'm in the head
it was pictures that I'm literally
watching go I can see this this is
unfolded so many times yeah I'll see
that that's exactly how the mannerisms
of the people you've captured that way
he's in traffic oh what do you want new
one station
and it's good to see that at the end the
SSC Brit is brilliant that's a massive
part of all the stuff as well so to see
the action taking place the builders
secure and everybody's into
interrogating talking to other people
Gathering all the equipment that's
really good for that SSC is basically a
forensics and evidence Gathering that's
the most important part of the art
nobody does or touches anything until
building secure is given so once that
they've said building security that
means there's no more x-rays no more
terrorists in there anybody needed
Medicals being dealt with everybody's
been you need to move to one room or
however you've decided to do that you're
looking for documentation you're looking
for any CDs or USBS that are lying
around uh any cameras any phones any
type of Radio Systems hard drives from
every computer you've searched behind
pictures because what they used to do
back in the day was
if the you know a lot of them would
video stuff the evidence that even have
a USB or an old-fashioned CD and the
sellotape them to the back of
pictures on the wall
that's overdie them so you take the you
know video of somebody go into a picture
turn around there it is you've got a
really older campus shot then you take
off into a bag sealed and what room it
was in it's documented this is all
happening very very quickly yeah that so
far that's the best one
down the first one it's a different
League to all the rest of them it's
that's very rude those first two are
very realistic and for me for me if I'm
playing it I got one of this where the
rest are all a bit crazy it's just it
was good entertainment you know trains
tipping off people driving a vehicle
there's no realism stuff but I get it
it's fun it's entertainment whereas
these if you want to step into the world
of an operator you've done it you're
just catching it there that's good and
you can see the differences from the
early ones to this
huge thanks to Billy Billingham for
joining us on this video If you enjoyed
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe as we've more on the way and
of course be sure to check out Billy's
new book all the links to which will be
in the description below thanks for
watching
[Music]